Republican Vice Presidential nominee
Sarah Palin
Sarah Palin knows a thing or two about
close elections Governor Sarah Palin of
the great state of Alaska
the former governor of Alaska is best
known for her unsuccessful vice
presidential run with John McCain in
2008 when he lost to Barack Obama you
can actually see Russia from Land here
in Alaska when Alaska went to the polls
to elect a new member of Congress in
August Palin found herself in a
three-way race we have just begun and we
it's it's a fight for what is right for
Alaska and for our nation but she was
defeated by Mary paltola
[Music]
who is now the first female Alaskan
native to be elected into the House of
Representatives being Alaska native is
part of my ethnicity but I'm much more
than my ethnicity and I'll be looking
forward to working forward uh
for all alaskans here in this in this
short seat the special election was
called after the death of the former
office holder Alaska has the highest
proportion of Native Americans in the
United States and the vote was the first
under a new system there with voters
listing candidates in order of
preference on the ballot
Governor Sarah Palin special special
person thank you and Palin is already
planning another comeback with an
endorsement from former president Donald
Trump she's gained support in a
historically Republican state after
peltola finishes this term she and Palin
are due to face off again in November in
a bid to fill this same congressional
seat for the next two years
Leah Harding Al Jazeera